los esfuerzos se centran en las labores
de rescate
también en la extinción del fuego
la tragedia ocurrió en cita cuna cerca
de chittagong en el sureste de
bangladesh
mientras los hospitales están saturados
y los locales buscan señales de vida de
los suyos
anoche hablé con mi hermano diez minutos
antes del accidente no hemos tenido
contacto con él desde entonces no
sabemos nada sobre su condición o
paradero todavía verdad el incendio se
produjo en la noche del sábado en un
depósito de contenedores en una empresa
que cuenta con participación de una
corporación de países bajos tras el
fuego vinieron múltiples explosiones
decenas de personas han muerto y
centenares están heridas la causa real
detrás del incidente se revelará cuando
se investigue no debo hacer una
evaluación basada en conjeturas hasta
donde sé la oficina del comisionado
adjunto formó un comité de investigación
el cuerpo de bomberos debe haber
iniciado una investigación por separado
o lo hará se trata de una nueva tragedia
en un país que destaca por el pobre
historial de seguridad industrial pese a
ser el segundo exportador textil del
mundo las regulaciones son laxas y los
índices de corrupción altos por lo que
los bangladesíes se acostumbraron a este
tipo de incidentes